happy Halloween everybody!
clap it up what are you do in halloween you clap that's right happy halloween
This we're gonna have to be honest now Marzia it's time to get real
Okay
You say it then
Yeah, it's the second time we shoot this video
Yeah, but we shot these like in february it was a long time ago and then i figured out we weren't recording the audio
and i was just like damn
But here we are again and we're here to talk about
Hausu
"The best horror movie of all time"- Marzia 2017
So you found this film it's a japanese horror film
We you show me the trailer and it looks insane the movie looks
Insane and i'm very excited to show it to you guys
Together with Marzia which showed it to me so it was made by Nobuhiko Obayashi
and his direction for making this film was that it was the japanese version of jaws
you know jaws
the one with the shark yeah that was the direction that he got from the studio they were like let make us a movie like jaws
really yeah which doesn't really make any sense
I mean now i see
the scene in, I don't wanna spoil it
it did really well in japan they didn't think it would do well
but their reviews were terrible
oh no
but then
they didn't understand it
Well the thing with Hausu is that it might seem like a really bad
Movie it's not it's a bad good movie but not it's so bad it's good it's just it's bad but it's still good
yeah I agree
you understand that
oh
okay, so she kept on school that's her Dad
you, love this scene
I do
A companion that's what you say when you bring on the new wife come out?
the sound of the wind only she gets hit btw
oh yeah the wind only effects her she looks like leia from star wars
oh
Yeah, that's how you know you're killing it?
So her name is actually gorgeous
Yeah, oh this this story is actually about seven girls right so i don't know we'll see them all later yeah
they all are just named after their personality mm-hmm it's great sayers when they introduced all the girls in the movie
and
It gets really weird it's just this guy my god how do we explain this to people
Well they are having it's summertime so they are all gonna go on volume together
this is the ben
that's how you fall right yes oh wow
how did that happen
Me show me whenever i fell down the stairs
i love the background that i clearly just like sets lord wrongs or whatever
Yeah, so funny this is seemed like a horror movie yet
yeah, why is her backdrop on it back dry they were clearly just like having a laugh making this film like
yeah, they tell you all the names now right
melody
professor
sweet as skin
comfort spring
mac, after big mac
probably yeah
So none of, the girls
were
actual like
actresses not real one like
not
really like upcoming maybe or like okay
what
why actually we need to get them in the mood was he would play the music on set
So i think that's why it's so bombarded by music all the time
but it kind of work like they don't seem that bad but apparently like everyone that worked on it were like that they're terrible
you, know it's not real it's just a backdrop against
making sure
what in the world
I think it was a bird but i don't some wanted us, to win hey
this is how you act by the way everyone does this right
and comfor gets attack
this must be so confusing but i'm confused if you think this is confusing she's standing me there
this is ridiculous
so a lot of the stuff that they did the special effects and the things they don't make any sense apparently he
asked his daughter for advice during the film hmm because he thought
it would give another perspective to stuff that grown-ups don't think about so they made
Special-effects kind of reflective of that as well they did they made a special thanks trying to make them look bad
but it also just seemed like something you would say afterwards like yeah we just
We didn't made the effects to make them look bad it's it's yeah
Wait, so her mom used to live there so
this is sort of the me
Oh, she sees her mom and think
and after this scene is when it goes apeshit i would say yes when he starts
mom today gray
can we get to the good bit she's getting killed by a mattress by the way this one just want to make sure
my mattress now well not the pillows anything but
how should we kill this girl the peelers get the pillows i think they just wanted the panty shot
oh
my god look at that any brighter by ten out of ten oh
Sergei oh my god why is it so a low framerate what in the world
no, this is they actually not messing up it's this, low framerate for no reason i
Think it's supposed to be like a style?
style is like
it's very annoying okay so all the girls pretty much died
Spoilers and they all died in the best way ever we have the mattress we have the bit but i think
this is one of the best one i can betsy and then conclude yeah
When the music is too good and you can't stop playing oh
Yeah, there's a skeleton in the back oh my god
and they're the goldfish oh wow
Yep that's oh wow oh?
wow
we again we were looking at a girl getting eaten by a camera through a fishbowl that's the level of it i
Feel like this is one of those things where they just tell them like i don't wanna buy it's going it's going
to look really great after the effects are in
don't worry about it
what's this
Yeah, so apparently they use my blue paint, for everything so they could just chroma key but clearly you see the blue
I saw it as, sort of like a copy of the shining
You, know how the guy just knows that he has to save the kid or whatever
There's a sin but yeah for some reason
Yeah, this one guy just realizes i'm gonna go save them yeah maybe we didn't get it though maybe we miss
you maybe my own
I don't
memphis is telling me this in japan
oh, wow what how
waves what was that that door dishes are coming for as well
That's the guy i'm trying, to save them
trying real hard my god the cat is so cool this shut my god what is happening
How's your back the cat destroy it of course oh, no oh yeah!
she gets sucked into the plan what is happening for the land most the lamb gets hurt
of course we get the mattress the well
The lamb
See i was just getting eaten by the land
Are you interested in this film this is compelling to you
wait but comfor comes back with her legs to kick that wow
wow
Oh, my god oh wow oh?
my god it's like they asked himself how many special effects can we fit in
this three second segment
our professors dead too bad she couldn't find her glasses what
it's very strange
But it's not being yet
That's heightened yes? Eimai oh?
wow i
guess they like it cut huh
well that was how soon
great in film i think is actually really good i'll be pleased keeping through like these this is
Confusing because it's confusing than just watching them but that's part of it you know if you get a bunch of friends oh?
Yeah it's a good time to watch for halloween and that's why it's on halloween
mmm-hmm, and if you appreciate the aesthetic of the film like
We do so apparently or by actually before, he was working on this film he was working on another project?
So it sort that product even though he was asked to take naked jaws
he was working on this kind of serious project and he kind of brought that into this film
And i we didn't notice it at all the first time we watched it at all i think
probably the message behind the film goes beyond your hand or whatever but apparently if i actually
grew up in hiroshima which was the city that got bombed from world war ii and
He lost all his friends they all his family and childhood friends who were gone so he wanted to make a movie that
described that
Losing everyone and i think he wanted to do it in a comedic way because it was
too bizarre to comprehend yeah in any other fashion even though it seems really silly how she get eaten by a
piano
thank you for letting me share this film with you mertz and
To have a great halloween everybody also buy my merch it's limited link in the description stop touching my nipple
Because i respect you mind see that's why?